today's IBM acronym quiz is lamp any  idea what it stands for here's a hint  it's a software stack that sites like  Wikipedia and most blog sites rely on  lamp is a web platform and each letter  is one of its components starting from  the bottom the L is for the Linux  operating system A is for Apache the web  server P is for PHP which is a  programming language and runtime  environment finally M is for MySQL an  open source database used by the  application written in PHP to get the  data for your page  the lamp stack has been around for more  than 20 years more recent Stacks worked  differently they split the business and  presentation logic between the server  and client browser versus a lamp-based  web application that is both on the  server did you get it right if so feel  free to brag in the comments